[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo les séquences fortes de la semaine
à l'assemblée et au sénat avec nous et
eric benqué sénateur communiste du nord
bonjour bonjour bonjour eric bocquet et
bien on va commencer par vous présenter
en quelques mots
éric bocquet vous êtes né à la bassée
dans le nord vous êtes sénateur
communiste du nord depuis septembre 2011
et vous avez été maire de marquillies un
village de 2000 habitants de votre
département pendant 22 ans
votre cheval de bataille l'évasion
fiscale vous avez été rapporteur de deux
commission denquête ausina sur le sujet
vous avez écrit un livre avec votre
frère d'ailleurs pour dénoncer cette
pratique alors sur 10 vous mettez
combien au gouvernement sur ce sujet ce
qu'ils traquent suffisamment les
fraudeurs non je le ferais un ennemi sur
10 vous êtes sévère
voilà un peu beaucoup mieux faire il ya
des discours volontariste mais dans les
faits et les actes et les décisions
prises on est lourd et très très loin du
compte encore aujourd'hui s'est habitué
à noter vous êtes en plus professeur
d'anglais
tout à fait alors on va dérouler la
semaine avec vous et éric bocquet la
catastrophe de lubrizol préoccupation
majeure du parlement le premier ministre
a dû s'expliquer devant députés et
sénateurs une commission d'enquêté une
mission d'information seront mis en
place
c'est le menu de l'automne le budget
2020 après leur passage devant les
députés les ministres étaient
auditionnés au sénat
l'occasion d'une passe d'armes sur l'
isf en un consensus rare à l'assemblée
en commission les députés ont voté à
l'unanimité une proposition de loi pour
mieux lutter contre les violences
conjugales
enfin le sénat au chevet des mères le
président de la commission des lois de
la chambre haute a proposé un plan
d'action pour donner un coup d'arrêt aux
violences contre les élus les
parlementaires veulent dissiper les
zones d'ombré autour de l'incendié de
l'usiné chimique lubrizol de rouen sujet
à la une du parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une commission denquête sera mise en
place au sénat ainsi qu'une mission
parlementaire à l'assemblée
le sujet s'est invitée cette semaine
lors des questions d'actualité le mardi
à l'assemblée le lendemain au sénat et
vous allez le voir
assailli de questions le premier
ministre a tenté de rassurer je
veillerai à ce que les mesures prises
pour l'indemnisation immédiate des
agriculteurs qui voient leur production
en vertu du principe de précaution
non commercialisé les riverains
l'ensemble de ceux qui subissent un
préjudice ou un dommage je veillerai à
ce que rien ne vienne exonérer la
responsabilité de l'industriel car en
fait d'installations classées le régime
juridique qui a été posé par la loi est
complétée par la loi prévoit qu'il ya
bien un responsable l'entreprise comme
pour la transparence le gouvernement et
l'état mettra tout en oeuvre pour dire
pour mesurer et pour faire connaître
l'ensemble des causes et des
conséquences de cet incendie de cette
catastrophe industrielle dont nous
souhaitons et dont nous allons veiller à
ce qu'elle ne devienne pas une
catastrophe sanitaire ou une catastrophe
environnementale
éric bocquet à partir du moment où la
catastrophe a été connu jusqu'à
aujourd'hui est ce que la communication
globale et notamment la communication de
crise du gouvernement a été bonne à la
hauteur de ce qui s'est passé j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya eu un peu de
patinage au début vu l'ampleur de la
catastrophe ses effets sur
l'environnement immédiat sur les
l'état de santé des gens sur l'air qu'on
respire est et dans un périmètre
absolument large et du cafouillage pour
vous il ya eu un peu des citations un
peu de patinage eux alors peut-être
qu'on peut le comprendre vu l'ampleur de
la catastrophe mais cela dit peut-être
qu'en amont il aurait fallu des
contrôles plus serrés parce que j'ai
constaté que entre 2003 et cette année
le nombre de contrôles est passé de 30
mille à dix huit mille par an contrôle
en amont sur ces 6 et les eaux voilà
donc il ya un sujet déjà en amont en
matière de contrôle et de régulation ça
va d'ailleurs faire l'objet bien des
travaux de des députés et des sénateurs
puisqu'il a une mission d'information à
l'assemblée une commission denquête au
sénat qu'est ce que vous en attendez
quels sont les pouvoirs de ces
commissions d'ailleurs je rappelle que
vous avez déjà rapporté 2 commission
denquête oui tout à fait une commission
denquête c'est un véritable outil
d'investigation
c'est sans doute l'expérience la plus
intéressante pour un parlementaire c'est
un vrai outil vous convoquez qui vous
voulez et les personnes que vous
entendez prête serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité comme on le ferait au
tribunal donc ça n'est pas rien les
propos tenus devant le commission
denquête peuvent être opposées en cas de
parjure éventuellement donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut avoir tous les outils de la
transparence s'il faut pas jouer
l'opacité et on voit aujourd'hui dans
l'opinion le la défiance est énorme
il a dit si des analyses qui sont faites
et de la parole publique dans son
ensemble s'est dit absolument si l'ap
ont filmé la défiance est un seul et dès
le début c'est très compliqué à
rattraper ensuite d'anglais faut mettre
tout le paquet les efforts pour que la
transparence absolue tous les moyens
soient donnés à ces commission denquête
pour obtenir tous les renseignements
nécessaires d'autres vous dites qu'une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire a
vraiment les voies moyens d'auditionner
de mener des investigations
même si il y à une enquête judiciaire en
cours
que peut apporter de plus cela une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire par
rapport à ce que ce que va apporter
l'enquète judiciaire je crois que les
fonctions sont pas les mêmes d'ailleurs
la sphère benalla au sénat a
parfaitement montré et philippe bas là
dessus était impeccable sans jamais
outrepassé les pouvoirs d'une commission
denquête sans jamais empiéter sur le
terrain judiciaire
je crois que les les actions sont
parallèles et complémentaires l'une de
l'autre
il n'y a pas d'inquiétude là-dessus je
tends plus complémentaires que là on
voit que beaucoup de parlementaires
veulent parler de l'ensemble des sites
seveso
il y en a beaucoup dans toute la france
il n'y est hélas on voit que il peut y
avoir des craintes pour de nombreux
départements exactement
c'est la dimension d'après l'an dernier
je crois qu'il ya eu plus d'un millier
d'incidents ou d'accidents sont des
sites seveso donc c'est dire que au delà
du problème de rouen il ya la généralité
des sites seveso en france et puis il
faudrait pas oublier dans la sphère
parce qu'on n'en a pas parlé beaucoup du
propriétaire de l'entreprise monsieur
warren buffet on va en parler dans un
instant mais on sait que toutes les
responsabilités soient établies juste
une question il ya une précédent azf ya
une grande commission d'enquêté a eu des
choses des conclusions qui ont été tirés
une loi tout ça ça n'a pas suffi on n'a
pas tiré les leçons pour vous de cette
catastrophe azf a complètement il ya
peut-être eu des freins il ya peut-être
eu des du lobbying je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas il faudra lever tous les
obstacles de quelque nature qu'il soit
alors elisabeth borne a été justement
auditionné en urgence à l'assemblée la
ministre du développement durable qui a
mille industriels dont vous parlais à
l'instant devant ses responsabilités il
s'agit d'une société américaine écoutez
il ya eu trente neuf inspections sur ce
site depuis 2013 et je le redis 10
inspection donc je je je pense pas que
ce soit effectivement fin qu'il y ait eu
une insuffisance de contrôle sur ce site
ou en tout cas à ce stade rien ne me
permet de de l'indiquer et sur l'état de
catastrophe technologique et la
responsabilité de l'industriel 1 je le
redis responsabilité de l'industriel
elle est tout à fait en pleine et
entière et c'est bien l'esprit de la
législation responsabilité pleine et
entière de l'industriel pour autant la
ministre n'en dit pas plus ça veut dire
quoi
il doit payer il doit y avoir il ya des
dégâts dans la sphère il ya des des
pollutions envisager d indemnisation des
agriculteurs des industriels de toute
l'économie du secteur
ça va avoir un coût mais monsieur warren
buffet qui n'a rien à voir avec
marie-george quatrième fortune du monde
à la tête de la holding propriétaire
l'entreprise de cette usine chimique 6
milliards de profits l'an dernier donc
je pense qu'il ya là de quoi un aliment
est largement et régler les problèmes
matériels là où ils se poseront vous
parler des dégâts notamment pour les
agriculteurs qu'en est-il dans le nord
il ya eu de très nombreux agriculteurs
qui ont été inquiets sur l'impact de ce
nuage de suie pour leur propre culture
et puis certains jugent aussi que et
bien toutes les mesures qu'on a fait
pour qu'il ne puisse
pas vendre leurs produits étaient trop
drastiques qu'est ce que vous en pensez
notre région est effectivement pas de
calais n'auront été touché apparemment
je pense à saint pol sur ternoise dans
le pas de calais dans le douaisis dans
mon département
forcément en 200 km à vol d'oiseau ce
n'est pas beaucoup et il semble qu'ils
aient effectivement des retombées sur
les cultures sur des films plastiques
emballant les ballots de paille par
exemple il ya des traces physiques
concrète de deux semaines
c'est normal que le principe de
précaution s'applique on limite la vente
de certains produits ce qui ne plaît pas
aux agriculteurs parce qu'ils s'estiment
sûr ils sont en difficulté les gens leur
demandent de mettre la rivière des sens
est normal que le principe de précaution
de précaution mais immédiatement après
il faut envisager l'indemnisation parce
que ça peut mettre en péril des
exploitations bien sûr eric boeck et on
passe à présent au deuxième thème de
cette émission
le budget 2009 le gouvernement le
présente comme le budget du pouvoir
d'achat après la crise des gilet jaune
alors les vannes sont elles ouvertes et
la stèle filet du déficit le texte a été
présenté cette semaine au sénat il est
très loin de faire l'unanimité
regardez ce sujet le samu à deux
chiffres c'est un budget post crise des
gilet jaune celui du pouvoir d'achat
promet le gouvernement qui prévoit 9
milliards d'euros de baisses d'impôts
pour les ménages en 2020
côté recettes l'exécutif mise sur la
baisse des taux d'intérêt qui devrait
rapporter 5 milliards d'euros pour la
droite le gouvernement n'a pas les
moyens de sa politique et creuse
dangereusement la dette de la france il
ya deux des baisses d'impôts qui sont
financés par de la dette et qu'ils sont
donc ils ne sont pas financés et ça
c'est évidemment pas acceptable on
abdique sur l'idée qu' on souhaite
reconquérir notre souveraineté
financière
les critiques sont encore plus virulente
à gauche où l'on ne croit pas à la
théorie du ruissellement des baisses
d'impôts pour les plus riches
auditionné cette semaine au sénat bruno
le maire a été vivement interpellé par
le président de la commission des
finances
vincent eblé a demandé il ya six mois
des éléments d'évaluation de l'impact de
la suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune
des questions restées sans réponse
je regrette que pour des raisons
juridiques que je trouve obscures le
sénat ne puisse pas être associée
directement au comité d'évaluation
qu'elle fait un travail tout à fait
remarquable en totale transparence sur
nos choix en terme de fiscalité du
capital juridique ces politiques
nous l'avons format fusée président
remettrait de le déplorer me représenter
à raison de un parlementaire pour la
chambre haute
un parlementaire pour la chambre basse
ne permet pas d'assurer la diversité de
notre représentation politique
le projet de loi de finances et ses 80
articles seront discutées au sénat fin
novembre les débats promettent d'être
agitées éric bocquet tout d'abord je
voudrais votre réaction à ce clash que
l'on vient d'entendre lors de l'audition
des ministres entre vincent eblé le
président de la commission des finances
et bruno le maire tout ça ça portait
notamment sur l'évaluation de la réforme
de l'isf est ce que ça ne reflète pas
aussi toutes les tensions qu'il ya
autour de cette réforme controversée et
qui est en cours d'évaluation
oui moi j'ai apprécié ce moment j'ai
adressé d'ailleurs un light au président
vin n'est pas habitué de ce d'avoir ce
ton effectivement mais je crois que ça
fait du bien parce que parfois ça
ronronne un peu en commission des
finances et là c'était pas le cas pas du
tout il a remis l'église au centre du
village rappelé l'existence du sénat sa
souveraineté son indépendance sa liberté
et son utilité dans le bicamérisme
français je pense que c'était salutaire
d'avoir ce petit message un peu clash et
sur le fond sur la réforme de l'isf
quel est votre avis à travers mal est en
cours d'évaluation et on a vu cette
semaine que ben france tractée j10 on
s'est un petit peu difficile à évaluer
ce qu on en connaîtra un jour réellement
les retombées pour vous ce qui est
difficile à évaluer si les retombées
pour l'économie réelle parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on nous a vendu la
suppression de l'sf l'impôt le plus
idiot du monde certains ont dit et donc
l'argent devait ruisseler naturellement
dans l'économie réelle l'investissement
les salaires etc
il n'en est rien ou en tout cas on le
dit aujourd'hui en termes galants
les effets sont difficiles à évaluer ce
qui est certain quand même c'est que ça
a profité aux 5% les plus riches c'est
pas un scoop 6500 euros de gains de
pouvoir d'achat dans l'année ça s'était
fixé il faut penser que le gouvernement
cache quelque chose que les
parlementaires ne sont pas assez associé
à ce travail d'évaluation
je ne sais pas s'ils cachent mais en
tout cas les parlementaires sont pas
respectés sont pas associés le mercredi
prochain 20 cents
blé de montgolfier vont présenter un
rapport sur voilà et sur la base mêmes
données auxquelles ils auraient dû avoir
accès à ce qu'elle me bercy a refusé de
communiquer la division jetair c'est le
coeur du pouvoir de contrôle du
parlement sur les mots c'est majeur
effectivement voté le budget de la
france
exécuter et contrôler l'action du
gouvernement c'est les fonctions de
coeur donc vous aurez des vous aurez des
chiffres sur le coût de cette
suppression de l'sf vous aurez des
chiffres nous les attendons nous
l'espérons vous n'avez pas encore donc
est-ce que globalement ce budget pour
vous et sincère est ce que parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de baisses d'impôts promises
j les poches gilet jaune on a dit est ce
que pour vous le gouvernement on peut
pas reprocher au gouvernement finalement
de vouloir baisser les impôts oui
évidemment c'est séduisant baisser les
impôts mais dans le même temps on
déshabille les services publics les
collectivités l'hôpital qui attendent
besoin on déshabille pierre pour
habiller paul en gros alors évidemment
baisser les impôts mais dans le même
temps on baisse les recettes de l'état
l'impôt n'est pas un problème mon choix
henry morgenthau secrétaire d'état au
trésor de roosevelt dans les années 30
disait l'impôt c'est le prix à payer
pour vivre dans un monde civilisé dans
les années 30 servir valable aujourd'hui
avant vous aviez la frilosité je ne vois
là et la crise et voilà les gilles et
jean et tous les conflits nous rappelle
qu'il ya delà de la mal vie dans ce pays
il ya des inégalités énormes alors on
habille ce budget de l'étiquette post
gilet jaune mais c'est un leurre
monsieur macron est un révolutionnaire
dangereux il a écrit un livre en 2016
révolution mais c'est une révolution
ultralibéral moins de services publics
moins de dépenses publiques
vous entendez aussi bien les critiques
plutôt de la droite sur le fait que le
déficit prévu pour 2020 est à 2,2 pour
cent du pib
c'est le plus bas depuis 20 ans indique
bruno le maire mais on est quand même
loin de ce qui était prévu dans la loi
de programmation à 1 25%
la dette elle flirte toujours avec 100 %
donc on est en queue du punk du peloton
européen ce que pour vous c'est quand
même aussi une source d'inquiétude le
dernier budget équilibré la france c'est
1974 ce fait 45 ans qu'on vit en déficit
conviait découvert c'est comme si la
france était chez cofinoga et les
marchés financiers continuent de nous
prêter alors il mais ça continue comme
ça depuis des alarmes avellan j'entends
bien mais alors qui sait
et on va encore payer cette année 49
milliards d'euros d'intérêts aux marchés
financiers
on réemprunte 200 milliards on re
prévoit en 2020 devrait emprunter plus
de 200 milliards d'euros et on nous
prête à taux négatifs on gagne de
l'argent en empruntant il ya un sujet ça
m'interpelle beaucoup ça un mot sur la
fraude fiscale un tout de même dans les
mesures qui sont contenues dans ce texte
le gouvernement veut traquer les réseaux
sociaux passés au crible les contenus
publiés sur internet a sauvé ça c'est
une bonne idée pour vous qui êtes
spécialiste de ce sujet je crois qu'il
serait mieux de garder les emplois de la
dg fip former les contrôleurs pour aller
voir les comptabilités entreprises des
grandes banques pour aller faire le
travail d'investigation plutôt que
s'amuser sur les réseaux sociaux
pourquoi pas rien mais oui c'est un
début de quelque chose c'est un outil
mais il ya des agents là on va encore
supprimer des milliers d'emplois dans la
dg fip qui serait bien utile en matière
direction générale des finances
publiques
éric bocquet on en vient cette
proposition de loi qui a été adoptée à
l'unanimité en commission des lois à
l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte doit permettre de mieux lutter
contre les violences faites aux femmes
il prévoit notamment la mise en place
d'un bracelet anti rapprochement
proposée par le député les républicains
aurélien pradié il a été adopté à
l'unanimité
fanny die la proposition de loi donc est
adopté l'image est rare
une proposition de loi du député lr
aurélien pradié soutenue par tous y
compris par la majorité
une telle immunité et consensus
politique sur un sujet sensible la lutte
contre les violences conjugales depuis
le début de cette année 111 femmes sont
mortes assassinées dans des conditions
d'extrême violence
111 ce chiffre noir doit nous obséder
111 pour faire plus plus fort plus vite
le texte comporte une disposition phare
un bracelet anti rapprochement pour les
conjoints violents
une mesure que le gouvernement promet
depuis plusieurs mois cela fonctionne
les espagnols nous le monde
aucun décès en dix ans pour les femmes
protégés grâce à ce bracelet le premier
ministre le souhaite aussi
la garde des sceaux également notre
proposition permettra de passer des
paroles aux actes
autre changement les ordonnances de
protection seront délivrés plus
facilement sans que la victime soit
obligé de porter plainte et plus
rapidement
six jours au lieu de un mois et demi en
moyenne actuellement
objectif faire vite pour répondre aux
situations d'urgence nous avons fixé six
jours parce que c'est ce qui existe
aujourd'hui en matière de référé c'est
une règle à peu près courante et et est
répandue et nous considérons que le seul
délai de 6 jours nous permet de
préserver à la fois les délais de
convocation les délais contradictoires
et la délivrance finale de l' ordonnance
de protection le plus lu le texte
prévoit aussi la possibilité pour les
victimes de demander un téléphone grave
danger sans passer par une association
conventionnée la proposition de loi sera
examinée dans l'hémicycle jeudi prochain
elle évoquait au delà du fond de ce
texte en obtenant que tout le monde vote
sa proposition de loi lejeune député
l'air at il pour vous fait à un petit
coup politique
je ne sais pas c'est pas ça ma
préoccupation dans l'occupation c'est
qu'effectivement il faut venir on n'est
les hanches court à ces femmes qui
subissent des violences et dont
certaines ne payent de leur vie
donc c'est normal qu'ils aient une
unanimité sur ce type de sujet
le contraire n'est pas normal pour vous
so lu ment il n'y a pas de débat
politique là dessus c'est une urgence
sociale moi je j'ai rencontré il ya
quelques temps le chef de brigade
gendarmerie de mon territoire qui me
disait que sur les interventions
réalisées sur le territoire sénateur du
nord voilà 80% étaient liés à des
violences intrafamiliales c'est énorme
dans un territoire comédiens qui n'est
pas particulièrement difficultés dont ça
interpelle 111 décès de femmes depuis le
1er janvier on avait cosigné une tribune
dans la presse au printemps dernier à
l'initiative de une sénatrice centriste
chez nous la suite' billon annick
président de la délégation et on avait
tous plus cette démarche cet appel fort
de tous les parlementaires à prendre des
mesures donc ça ça va pas y avoir de
dissonances sur ce type de sujet pour
vous ni au sénat ni à la non ça doit
faire l'unanimité partout mais c'est pas
toujours le cas à éric bocquet il ya eu
parfois je me rappelle de deux textes
par exemple sur la pédophilie à l'école
ou ce genre de choses bien il n'y avait
pas toujours eu des l'unanimité entre
des propositions de loi et des projets
de lois parfois on se se disputent même
csu jan aps le gouvernement et les
parlementaires muet sur les sujets
sociétaux comme cela oui mais là il
s'agit de vies humaines
il n'y a pas des tergiversations avoir
franchement il y avait une proposition
de loi justement présenté par le même
député aurélien pradié sur le handicap
elle n'avait pas été voté parce qu'à
l'époque la majorité un public en marche
avec des consignes de ne pas voter des
amendements de l'opposition pour vous
c'était pas normal ça en pareille le
handicap ça fait partie de la mission
dont j'ai le contrôle avec arnaud bazin
au sénat sénat mission solidarité
insertion égalité des chances qui inclut
essentiellement à queue mais la
thématique du handicap
il faut mettre le paquet là aussi on a
un retard considérable en matière du
handicap dans ce pays donc là ça va
faire absolument consensus avec des
moyens réels pour avancer est-ce que ça
prouve aussi que et bien les
parlementaires de la république en
marche et bien on gagne en expérience et
qu'il arrive désormais à accepter
davantage les apports de l'opposition
écoutez quand ils sont pas godillot
certains sont certainement compétent sur
plein de sujets ça c'est incontestable
mais sur des sujets comme cela on peut
que les soutenir ils ont aussi tiré les
leçons du bad buzz qui avait eu à
l'époque on se rappelle que françois
ruffin sur la question du handicap
étaient venus voler au secours
d'aurélien pradié en dix ans est
complètement anormal que le gouvernement
bien ne veulent pas accepter cette
proposition tout la proposition de la
été rejetée absolument c'est scandaleux
franchement sur un sujet comme celui-là
c'est scandaleux eh bien on va désormais
passer au dernier thème de cette
émission
éric bocquet ces deux derniers thèmes et
bien ce sont les maires agressé c'est
l'élu le plus proche de ses administrés
le plus populaire de la république
pourtant les maires font face à de plus
en plus d'incivilités d'injures et
d'agression après la mort du maire de
signes l'été dernier la commission des
lois du sénat a lancé une grande
consultation
béatrice faisant j'ai été victime d'une
tentative de meurtre avec une voiture
comme une arme pour me tuer deux
interventions chirurgicales plus de six
mois d'arrêt j'ai reçu des impacts de
balles sur la vitrine des locaux de mon
activité professionnelle
ma maison a été incendiée la nuit du 1er
janvier 2013
des témoignages de mères recueillis par
la commission des lois du sénat à
l'issue de sa grande consultation
initiée le 13 août dernier après la mort
du maire de signes le constat est
affligeant sur les 3800 12 et lui avoir
répondu 92% ont déjà été victimes
d'incivilités d'injures de menaces ou
d'agressions physiques grand
enseignement de cette enquête
parlementaire
les mères se sentent seuls abandonnés et
sans moyens pour lutter contre les
violences dont ils font l'objet
pour répondre à cette solitude la
commission des lois propose donc un plan
d'action il faut qu'il y ait davantage
d'amande qu'ils soient pas des amendes
pénales c2d prononcée par un tribunal
mais d abord administrative c'est à dire
prononcé par le maire un plan d'action
qui s'articule autour de douze mesures
visant à renforcer l'autorité des maires
conforter leurs moyens d'action et mieux
les protéger dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions des mesures qui seront
intégrées au projet de loi engagement et
proximité discuté au sénat à partir du 8
octobre prochain
on a entendu éric bocquet philippe bas
qui part d'un certain nombre de
témoignages qu'il a reçue par milieu il
ya notamment ce témoignage est reçu neuf
coups de couteau
j'ai été annoncé mort au journal de 20
heures est ce que ce n'est pas glacé
oui c'est tout à fait classant c'est une
étape de plus dans le mal être profond
qui s'est installée chez les mères qui
datent pas d'aujourd'hui
je me souviens qu'en début de ce mandat
qui s'achève la première année dans mon
département du nord il y avait eu autant
de démission que dans tout le mandat
précédent
donc il y avait des signes très forts
des maires les adjoints des conseillers
municipaux jette l'épongé parce qu'il
n'a pas d'hier et ça s'explique à mon
avis ya d'abord les côtés finances des
gens se sont été élus en 2014 avec plein
de projets pleins d'idées et sont rendus
compte que finalement ils n'auraient pas
les finances pour mettre en oeuvre leurs
leurs programmes leurs promesses
électorales parce qu'on à baisser les
dotations parce qu'on les a gelé après
on a créé de grandes intercommunalités
pour la transférer de plus en plus de
compétences la territoriale voix qui ont
dépossédé de plus en plus les communes
de leur pouvoir de la prérogative
et puis les normes les normes les mères
n'en peuvent plus de ces complications à
l'infini dans leur vie quotidienne et 4e
aspect une société qui va pas bien comme
le premier échelon de la république
c'est le maire et le maire c'est devenu
le dernier rempart de la république donc
ça veut dire que s'attaquer au maire de
cette façon-là très violente c'est
s'attaquer à un république à la
démocratie c'est la dernière digue il et
j'espère de tout mon coeur que la
campagne des municipales qui va
s'engager
ça peut être l'occasion de retisser un
lien en bas entre la population et les
élus parce que le maire il s'en sort
bien dans l'appréciation que l'opinion à
des mères ils sont à 75 sont 18%
favorable quand les parlementaires sont
à 10% pas photo donc il faut s'appuyer
cette force et comment faire pour les
protéger
on est l'épreuve alors oui les
propositions que les propositions qui
sont faits meilleure protection
judicieuse c'était une mesure
prioritaire pourrait permettre de
répondre à cette recrudescence de faire
confiance au maire faire confiance aux
moeurs à sa passe pas par la loi
non mais ça ça passe par une série de
mesures leur donner les moyens
financiers d'assumer leurs missions
laissé à la commune devrait pouvoir de
réaliser les choses voilà segalen c'est
un travail de longue haleine
le projet de loi engagement et proximité
à ce projet de loi sur le statut de
l'élu qui est examinée la semaine
prochaine les donne aux maires des
pouvoirs de police administrative celui
donner plus d'autorité mais est ce que
le risque en même temps c'est pas de le
mettre plus en danger moi je suis très
sceptique bon là on va renforcer les
aspects judiciaires protection d'accord
mais si on règle pas les autres
questions là que je viens d'évoquer on
va rien régler
c'est pas un super gendarmes le maire
oui voilà il ya des gendarmeries dans
les territoires ruraux il faut donner
aux gendarmes les murs à mieux
coordonner peut-être si avec elle les
gendarmes avec la police parfois ils
sont bien qui via les échanges
naturellement sur les toits avec
l'effort gendarmerie ça se passe très
bien on se connaît voilà mais ce qu'ils
ont toujours les moyens de leur mission
là aussi la question se pose des
véhicules dans lesquels on peut même pas
faire le plein parfois pour rouler la
nuit est un sujet on en est là et bien
merci eric bocquet d'avoir été l'invité
de cette émission parlement et dont on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine merci
eric bocquet merci katia effectivement
se retrouve la semaine prochaine avec un
député
[Musique]